40 people work at Yanina Mertzes company
survey she founded it when she was just
24 and took out a loan to do so it was
12 had I realized what it entails how
much you have to do I would have been
more hesitant I might not have had the
confidence to grow the company to what
it is today but not knowing is a form of
protection against unnecessary worrying
because ultimately you can make it work
so they started out in an apartment now
its premises spans several floors after
studying economics Yanina Mirza went to
work with a trade association but she
didn't feel sufficiently challenged and
eventually made the switch to the tech
sector it's called a mukesh as a woman I
get invited to give presentations
relatively often because it said there
are so few women in the industry you're
more conspicuous if you're the only
woman in the room I attended an event
last week with 50 car parts suppliers
from Germany and I was indeed the only
woman for that reason alone a lot of
people know me company conducts opinion
polls online and says their
representative on topics such as
attitudes towards the European Union
around 2000 polls conducted by survey
are currently online
if you're Muslim Hindu versus mass and
cloud food it was vital we had
credibility and in that respect to
network is a very helpful media major
media organizations such as Sri Galan
line or various regional outlets such as
the tonnage speaking newspaper in Berlin
trust the data we provide and that goes
to show that we have credibility how do
her colleagues feel about having a young
woman as a boss when we have discussions
I feel we get to the point much faster
it's all much less political than with
men I think it's good that she can admit
to making mistakes she'll actually say
okay I got that wrong it's important to
learn from mistakes and admit to them
hard-working and efficient yeah I think
that's that's we're in Germany she has
to be efficient no working late into the
night is nothing unusual at survey the
boss demands a lot of her staff the
company is based in Berlin where lobby
groups seek to influence policy making
Ioannina matzah belongs to an
association for start-up entrepreneurs
I'm very pleased to have been invited to
join the board and support the
association's work I do it first and
foremost as an entrepreneur not as a
woman but if I can be a role model and
encourage women then that makes me happy
for Suleiman flector had a moody few
nanometers
in this cafe and downtown Berlin Yanina
Matta is interviewing a prospective
employee she's hoping to expand into the
United States think big is part of cives
philosophy as is promoting gender
equality if they're equally qualified
we'd hire a woman rather than a man
especially for a team that's
male-dominated but we also have teens
that are exclusively female such as our
marketing team it would be great if a
man started there Yanina Mucha hopes the
company will turn a profit this year and
once that's happened she'll take a long
vacation